peu
[Musique]
e
cet homme qui au mois de mai 1939
accompli lui même le mouvement qui va
permettre au pétrole d'arabie de
s'engouffrer dans les flancs d'un
pétrolier
cet homme là est un roi il s'appelle
hymne séoul
[Musique]
c'est le même roy qui le 13 novembre
onze ans plus tard va également envoyer
lui même le pétrole due à sa dans le
pipe line
à peine achevée qui va permettre à ce
pétrole de traverser les déserts les
montagnes pour à 1783 kilomètres de là à
revenir à saïda et de là au monde entier
et chaque jour par ce même 'pipeline' 41
millions de litres de pétrole s'en iront
vers le mot
comment imaginer que l'homme qui venait
de donner ce signal qui venait de sa
main ordonné au pétrole de courir à
travers les déserts les montagnes et les
plaines jusqu'à la méditerranée cet
homme c'est au tout puissant
un demi siècle plus tôt était plus
pauvres qu'aucun homme mots qu'avec une
poignée de compagnons il était au sein
du désert le plus inhospitaliers à bout
de force à bout de soif à bout de misère
à bout de file
ils attendaient la mort comment imaginer
que partie de ciba une soirée b6 aurait
justement vouloir l'arrêt
cette ascension inouïe ce contraste tel
qu'il n'en existe pas d'autre dans
l'histoire je crois que c'est vouloir
ressusciter une histoire vraie qui
ressemble à ces chansons de geste qu'il
y a dix siècles pour raconter dans nos
contrées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
tout commence en laâbi bien sûr et tout
commence avec l'islam parce que l'islam
est né en arabie c'est en arabie que
mahomet a reçu la parole d'allah sept
ans ramic mahomet a conçu le coran
alors tout est parti de là l'épopée
fulgurante la conquête de tout le bassin
méditerranéen les siècles de
civilisation arabe
[Musique]
au liban
et puis peu à peu le coran avait fait
place à des appétits plus terrestre et
dans des villes somptueuse qui se
trouvait aussi bien sur les bords de
l'euphrate qu'en espagne à damas au
caire et bien les hommes les musulmans
comme les autres avait voulu vivre aimer
la vie et précisément dans cette ville
de dara yahoo je ne trouve maintenant
qui a été fondée au xvème siècle et bien
la foi musulmane régner dans toute sa
pureté
mais il y avait un homme qui était né
dans le ned jour en 1503 et qui
s'appelait mohamed ibn abdel wahab qui
s'inflige de voir que dans les villes
même d'arabie il y avait des scories
presque d hérésie par rapport à la
religion à la vraie religion du prophète
et il s'inflige est aussi que dans le
désert il y avait beaucoup de tribus qui
avait complètement oublié ni cela est
cet homme mohamed abdellaoue a décidé de
de prêcher un retour à la vraie religion
vous savez des réformateurs il y en a
dans toutes les religions saint bernard
et lutter en ce qui concerne le
christianisme ont été des réformateurs
et bien abdulwahab halte être le
réformateur de l'islam en arabie mais il
a fallu pour cela une rencontre ici dans
cette ville de daria vivait un prince
valeureux et puissant qui s'appelait
mohamed m ses hôtes
nous y voici nous sommes donc au xviiie
siècle et la famille des saoud et c'est
venu ici dans cette ville de daria
s'installer au xvème siècle et depuis
quelques dizaines d'années s'était
laissé août qui régnait sur cette vie et
m'hamed ims et oud lui aussi ceux des
les vous avez deux hommes qui ne se
connaissaient pas encore et qui était
désolé réciproquement
mohammed bin saud regretté que cette
arabique il aimait qui était son pays sa
terre soit divisé en quantité de prince
de tribus qui se faisaient la guerre
d'une manière continue sporadiques et il
rêvait à une unité de la ddt et bien
c'est cette rencontre qui allait être à
l'origine de tous pour affirmer sa
doctrine
il fallait à abdelwahab un sabre et pour
affirmer son esprit de conquête
il fallait à mohamed msp est rude une
doctrine et justement les deux hommes
unis vont faire que l'unité de l'arabie
va être amorcées du vivant de mohamed
ndao et cela va se continuer par son
fils abdel aziz et puis par le fils
d'abdulaziz que l'on appellera séounes
le grand et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi parce que c'est ou de legrand
partant de cette ville de narnia nous
sommes allés carrément conquérir la
majeure partie de l'arabie compris la
mecque et médine s'avancer jusqu'au
yémen
c'est ou de legrand une mérite son nom
savez vous que c'est où le vent a même
eu des contacts avec napoléon mais il
est mort trop tôt
et dès qu'il est mort les turcs les
turcs qui étaient les suzerains
nominatif de l'arabie mais ne m'était
jamais les pieds mais les terres qui
avait vu avec une grande inquiétude cet
empire se constituer en profiter du fait
que le successeur d'anne co2 abdallah
ses successeurs n'était pas de force et
ils ont envoyé une armée en arabie
commandé par mehmet ali mais métallique
était le vice roi d'égypte et cette
armée a écrasé cet empire arabe qui
venait de naître
abdallah par trahison a été arrêté a été
chargée de chêne a été conduit à
constantinople et là il a été décapité
de vente sainte sophie
c'en était fini du royaume uni
raby et même cette ville daria cette
capitale qui rayonnait depuis trois
siècles
et bien cette capitale mais m lille a
rasé c'est ce qui vous expliquent que
les ruines
nous voyons autour de nous le silence
s'est de nouveau appesanti sur la habits
troublée seulement par les caravanes qui
allait comme elle allait depuis des
millénaires à la recherche de leur
nourriture certes mais aussi de leur
vérité un jour à riyad la capitale qui
avait remplacé derrière un jeune prince
est né c'était en 1876 et on l'a appelé
abdul s il est né dans une capitale
certes mais cette capitale n'était
qu'une grosse bourgade
il est né dans un palais bien sûr mais
ce ballet était le plus simple les
palais et pourtant
abdel aziz portait dans ses veines le
sens de l'une des familles les plus
anciennes d'arabie il y avait beaucoup
de gloire
derrière lui beaucoup d'héroïsme
beaucoup de souvenirs mais présentement
il n'y avait surtout beaucoup de misère
les deux frères aînés de son père
rainier sur ce petit royaume du nec son
père abdourahmane se consacrait surtout
à l'enseignement du coran
[Musique]
et les naturelles qu'il est enseigné à
bhl existe d'abord le corps abdourahmane
veiller sur la pureté de la religion
quoi à beast
alors pas de chair trop riffs pas
d'habits trop luxueux
pas même de musique et même les rires
étaient déconseillés
oui les puritains du désert même du
rahmane
n'oubliez pas l'héritage qu'ils avaient
reçu pour le transmettre à son fils et
souvent ils disaient à cet enfant qui
grandit c'est n'oublie pas que tes
ancêtres ont fait la grandeur de
l'arabie et qui l'ont porté par tous la
parole de dieu telle que dieu l'a dit à
son prophète
il faudra que tu refasses la grandeur de
l'arabie et que tu redonnes à tous la
vraie parole de dieu dire cela un enfant
de 8 ans will le disait
et en même temps lui donner les moyens
de son ambition à 8 ans abdul aziz était
capable de rattraper à cheval au galop
woods bondir en selle sans étriers
il était un merveilleux tireur il manie
le sabre admirablement et son père de
confier les caravanes pour qu'il marche
pendant des centaines et des centaines
de kilomètres pour qu'ils savaient et
chaque matin deux heures avant le soleil
pour qu'il apprenne à vivre d'un peu
d'eau et de quelques dates de lait de
chamelle
c'est cela l'enseignement du désert
c'est cela qui fait ses armes
exceptionnels que sont les des doigts et
c'est alors qu'un certain rachid va
intervenir dans cette histoire le père
d'abdourahmane avait nommé le grand-père
de rachid gouverneur de l'un des
territoires de son royaume la province
montagneuse de chaman
voilà c'est que cette famille des rachid
avait peu à peu pris son indépendance
c'est un peu comme chez nous en france
quand les ducs de bourgogne qui tenaient
leurs pouvoirs du roi de france était
devenu quasi autonome chez eux et
avaient menacé le roi france et rachid
qui est un homme affalé nos missions
regarde maintenant du côté de ryad qui
est une belle ville et se dit et
pourquoi pas annexer ryad
pourquoi ne pas faire de rien d'une de
mes villes et comme il n'a aucun
principe et bien rachid qui a une arme
est beaucoup plus puissante que celle de
la famille de sa haute marche sur yann
et la grosse armée de rachi écrase la
petite armée de sa vie voilà rachid qui
est maître de rien
il faut dire que
il se conduit pas d'une manière cruelle
trop dur avec les princes de la maison
saout puisque à abderrahmane et à son
frère abdallah il offre de rester
gouverneur de la ville de riyad mais
comme abdellah ben à mourir d'ailleurs
de mort naturelle peu de temps plus tard
cette app de rahman qui devient
gouverneur au nom de rachid de riadh
cette même un paradoxe mais abderrahmane
accepte cela vaut mieux que rien il
ronge son frein
mais il accepte alors abdramane en ce
temps là est encore jeune et solide et
au fond il est chez lui
rachid de loin ressent quelques
inquiétudes sur abderrahmane est un
danger un envoi une armée pour
surveiller abdourahmane une armée
commandée par un certain salem et cela
me déteste les seins il faut dire qu'ils
l'approuvaient puisqu'il a mis à mort de
sa propre main 3 neveu de bram
car évidemment entre le gouverneur
abdourahmane que le militaire
d'occupation que salam eh bien il ya des
conflits qui vont être c'était
prévisible qui manqua ça va dégénérer en
suspicion ouverte en méfiance ouverte
évidemment salem se dit mon maître est
trop bon il n'aurait pas dû laisser
vivants c'est abdou rahmane il faut le
mettre hors d'état de nuire
elle profite de la fin d'une fête
religieuse pour annoncer qu'il va venir
présenter ses compliments abu rahma sans
but sans plan c'est de réunir la famille
d'abderrahmane autour de lui et de la
massacrer tout entier et voilà c'est
qu'il faut les complices pour une
affaire de ce genre
et quand il ya trop de complices on
parle et abderrahmane est prévenu
donc les deux hommes sont à égalité ça
ne s'annonce à birmal le reçoit et il a
près de lui son jeune fils abdel aziz
qui a 14 ans et m
il avoue le cap du logis soit là pour
assister à la scène cela fera partie de
son éducation
mais abu rahma nakache et tout autour de
la pièce des hommes armés ses propres
fidèles et leur a dit quand je dirais
mon poignet vous entrerez et vous
mettrez à mal les gardes de sel
cela se passe comme prévu sa famille se
présente avec sega et au moment où l
homme dit mais seigneur pourquoi n'as tu
pas ta famille autour de toi je ne vois
que ton fils abdel aziz fait venir les
autres membres de ta famille berman
c'est pourquoi il appelle ses membres de
sa famille il tire son pagne à ses
fidèles sortent de partout et on arrête
immédiatement
salem on arrête ses gardes il y en a un
qui est tué qui a voulu tirer lui-même
sont les pays les tuer mais tout le
monde est à rennes et abderrahmane est
redevenu maître de sa ville de rien mais
abdourahmane mais une même pas naïf il
sait parfaitement que rachid va courir
ce qui ne manque pas d'arriver et voilà
rachid avec son armée devant ryad alors
que faire bienvenue rahman choisi de
négocier s'il avait prévu ça depuis
longtemps il envoie une délégation
harrachie en lui disant je te rends ton
ami salem si tu te retires avec temps là
et comme rachid tient beaucoup à
récupérer salam sall fait beaucoup de
peine si on supprime es salam eh bien
ils acceptent l'offre
il récupère salem et il s'en va avec son
ami et voilà que ap d'uramin va régner
sur sa ville de riyad sans contrôle
comme avant comme il en a le droit
il va régner en paix pendant halloween
une petite caravane dans le désert
c'est l'image dont se souviendra toute
sa vie abdulaziz devenu ims et oud
pourquoi et bien parce que un moment
donné rachid a eu des difficultés avec
une population qui habite une région qui
s'appelle le casser et ces gens du qasim
sont vus proposer une alliance
abdourahmane qui n'a pas résisté alors
tout se passait très bien à durham en
plus les gens lui kassim mais bien sans
doute un letton venir à bout du fameux
rachid deux pas du tout rachid est
arrivé une fois de plus avec son arme et
a écrasé complètement les gens du
casting
abdourahmane a compris que maintenant
s'il attendait davantage ce serait
rachid qui lui ferait son affaire et les
parties il a préféré partir avec sa
femme ses fils et quelques fidèles et
les voilà justement dans le désert c'est
ça cette image la famille dhabi raciste
dans le désert
puis ils vont se réfugier d'abord dans
une région voisine du qatar c'est une
région c'est une région qui est occupée
par les turcs il ya la nuit des
occupants turcs mais la population comme
partout supporte mal les dieux et les
turcs vont voir arriver avec inquiétude
du rahman qui est très bien accueilli
par les populations
les populaires cure series mon dieu
abderrahmane ce serait quand même mieux
dans sa ville à ryad qu'ici c'est
peut-être demain l'éventualité d'un
soulèvement sous le commandement est
dure à mal et à messager du sultan turc
y arrive et bien faire des propositions
abdourahmane 2010 veux-tu rentrer dans
ta ville veut tu rentrais dans la
capitale à ryadh le sultan est prêt à
appuyer atd avec ses forces mais il faut
que tu lui promettent de devenir son
bassin une sainte colère alors sous les
vagues dur à mal et je crois que s'il
avait une cravache il aurait cravacher
l'envoyé des sultans turquie lui dit
mais comment vassal du sultan qui a fait
décapiter mon prédécesseur abdallah
jamais allé le lui dire jamais
je laisse agir par pour constantinople
et là évidemment quand il apporte aux
sultans parole de cet auteur du sultan
d'être furieux et il déclare que
désormais abderrahmane et hors la loi
c'est à dire que tout le monde aura le
droit désormais de le tuer à n'importe
où n'importe
voilà pourquoi poursuivi de toute part
abderrahmane fille avec ses deux fils
abdel aziz mohamed et une vingtaine de
fidèles
et comme ils ne peuvent aller nulle part
il se trouve à l'orée d'un véritable
désert parce que l'arabie n'est pas tout
entier un désert comment la tendance à
le penser qu'il ya de la végétation
l'arabie clairsemé mais il y en a eu
d'ailleurs les grands troupeaux de
chamelle trouve un peu partout de quoi
peut être mais au sein de ce faux désert
émis un vrai désert
c'est un endroit où il semble que
personne n'ait rien ne pourrait survivre
vous savez comment les arabes l'appelle
là-bas le quartier vide là n'y a pas un
buisson
y'a pas un brin d'herbe uniquement des
roches et des roches le soleil accablant
de lauwe il y en a mais elle est
tellement saumâtre que l'on ne peut pas
la boire alors c'est là dans ce qu un
géographe a appelé la contrée la plus
inhospitalières du monde c'est la
capture ammann ses fils
on se réfugie alors il n'y a personne
dans cette contrée bien si il aurait
voulu lui a quand même des gens qui
vivent là on les appelle des morasses
est une tribu étrange singulier et ils
vivent comme ils ne boivent que le lait
de leur chat mère est autrement ils
attrapent des lézards dans le désert
qu'ils font griller dans le savent c'est
ça à l'humour et nous savons qu'au début
abdulaziz a détesté les morales était le
contraire de ce qu'il aimait et puis il
a pris peu à peu à les connaître et
surtout estimé leur connaissance
extraordinaire du désert de la nature
pourquoi parce que pour survivre dans ce
qui est un enfer il faut utiliser la
moindre ressource de cet enfer ils
connaissaient et plus tard avec
admiration émoussé au dira savez-vous
qu'en lisant les empreintes d'un chameau
il était capable de dire d'où venait ce
chemin
le sexe ce chemin et même à goulens que
les vérifier en voix
alors il admire les murailles surtout il
est à l'école il vivra comme un petit
mourad
mais avec la même manière de vivre de
s'habiller et fera avec les razzias
qu'on appelle des gaz ou la nuit
on s'élance vers une tribu on avance en
silence
on en voit un enfant qui va couper les
liens des chameaux attaché qui
silencieusement au péril de sa vie va
tirer le chameau tendre il a fait ça le
petit abdel aziz ne considérant pas cela
comme répréhensible c'est en quelque
sorte le grand jeu admis du désert les
autres on avait autant à faire pour les
mois lors il a connu ce l'éducation du
désert là marcher pieds nus sur les
pierres chauffées à blanc le soleil de
midi
l'hiver il a dormi lors qu'il gèle
dehors avec presque rien sur le corps
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que cela
fait bizarre et extraordinaire sommes
une éducation pareil cela fait ibn saoud
et puis après des saisons un hiver
particulièrement dur et vraiment il n'ya
plus rien dans le quartier il plus rien
et à bout de force les fidèles
abderrahmane sont partis les uns après
les autres il n'y a plus qu'une poignée
d'hommes
abderrahmane le réuni leur dis mes amis
nous allons mourir c'est la volonté de
dieu ne refusons pas la volonté de dieu
prions et alors on entend dans la nuit
une voix juvénile répondre non nous
n'allons pas mourir c'est abdul aziz et
son père le regard des années pourquoi
dis-tu cela parce que je le faisais et
parce que je sais que moi je régnerait
sur tout larbi et un silence tous ces
hommes qui regardent l'adolescent il est
devenu l'adolescent il a 15 ans
et on entre en prière toute la nuit et
au matin on voit venir de loin sur un
chameau un message est un message et de
l'émir du koweit qui est venu dire mon
maître a appris que tu es aboud
souffrance avec les tiens il n'admet pas
qu'un seigneur comme toi traverse de
telles épreuves il t'offre l'hospitalité
au koweït
abderrahmane a cru que cette étude
manière de miracle en effet il pouvait
le penser en fait ce n'était pas ça du
tout c'était au contrat de la haute
politique
les turcs n'étaient pas très rassurée de
savoir à bure à man dans le désert hors
de la portée de leur regard parce qu abu
rahma ne s'en méfier toujours en
revanche le savoir à koweit et bien là
il préférait parce qu'ils avaient des
agents pourraient toujours savoir ce que
faisait abdramane tout simplement les
turcs s'étaient adressés aux sultans
n'co est élu avait demandé sans du tout
se référer à eux les turcs de s'adresser
aberrahmane spontanément et de lui
offrir l'hospitalité et voilà pourquoi
et comment un vieux rahman avec sa
famille dont son fils abdel aziz va
venir s'installer à koweït
et c'est à connaître quelques temps plus
tard à l'âge de 15 ou 16 ans comme tous
les jeunes musulmans de cette époque-là
qu'abdel aziz vince marine et nous
savons qu'il a beaucoup aimé sa jeune
femme qui malheureusement est morte six
mois après le mariage il a beaucoup
pleuré cette jeune femme
mais il ne s'en est pas moins remarier
c'est la destinée d'un prince musulmans
comme abdel aziz de se marier et au fil
des années le prendra les quatre femmes
que le coran l'autorisé à prendre et il
aura aussi il faut lier ou une infinité
de concubine
ce n'est pas avec quatre femmes qu'on
donne naissance à 43 fils et 10 les
chroniques locales une vingtaine de
films moi je pencherais plutôt pour une
quarantaine de filles ne serait ce que
pour équilibrer les sexes alors abdel
aziz et le futur hymne séoul a toujours
beaucoup aimé les femmes et il a sans
cesse répété à ses amis je remercie dieu
de m'avoir permis ce plaisir qui a été
le plus grand de ma vie de si bien et
tant aimé les femmes et ces sujets ont
toujours été très fier de la virilité du
royaume co2
mais voyez-vous il ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que ces mariages
ces femmes qu'il prend et bien il est
choisi dans des tribus différentes parmi
des peuples d'arabie différents pourquoi
parce que ce sont déjà des mariages
politique et ce sont toujours des
mariages politique car une pensée sera
le sel toute sa vie dit mme senut faire
l'unité de l'arabie est bien le mariage
c'est un moyen et cette couette que va
vivre et se transforme et maintenant
abdel aziz
parce que le nouveau sultan moubarak l'a
pris en amitié et à biot l'asie se rend
souvent empalé là dans ce palais qu'est
ce qu'ils découvrent bien des étrangers
des gens qu'il n'a jamais vue ils voient
des russes ils voient des anglais voit
des indiens il voire même des allemands
et puis il découvre aussi des banquiers
et marchands des négociants des
navigateurs en quelque sorte le regard
d'abdelaziz s'ouvre sur la vie et disons
le c'est pour lui pour son avenir à
tourner en capital mais le jeune abdoul
aziz qui a 20 ans qui descendent par sa
mère d'une tribu où les hommes sont tous
des géants et qui est lui même un géant
il a deux mètres de haut
l'argent proportion tout en muscles tout
en force et en intelligence abdulaziz
dit à son père puis à moubarak
chez des informations rachid est pas
retourné ariane il est loin derrière
pourquoi n'irait pas prendre rien ma
baraque leur garde et dur à mal le
regardent et disent oui il est capable
de prendre ian
d'accord
alors il réunit au koweit 40 fidèles 40
gaye parmi lesquels il y à l'un de ses
fidèles de toujours jean louis son frère
mohamed 40 hommes qui sur leurs chameaux
s'élance dans gazet veria et voilà que
après tant d'années abdulaziz revit très
exactement ce qu'il avait vécu avec son
père après la chute de riads
que savez-vous où il va se réfugier
comme autrefois dans le quartier vite
mais oui il va retrouver le quartier
vider les voix lasse les hommes
poursuivis qui non seulement se retrouve
en enfer mais ne doivent pas faire
savoir qu'ils sont en enfer
alors il efface toutes les traces de
leur passage pas d'empreinte pas de
foyers d'ici le fonio ils sont là
connaissent de nouveau la fin soit or
voici que le ramadan approche
eh bien voyez vous aussi peut-être
épisode le plus stupéfiant de cette
histoire stupéfiants ils vont suivre les
règles du ramadan comme n'importe quelle
croyance est eux qui ne mange rien ne
mangeront encore moins que rien disent
que le mangement ya du tout pendant
toute la journée
le lever au coucher du soleil gardant
pour la nuit le peu de lait de chamelle
qu'ils ont ou quelques lézards grillé
moi je dis que des hommes qui sont
capables de cela outrepassent les
limites de la volonté humaine
et au bout de 28 jours les énergies de
tous ces hommes sont tellement soudé à
celle d'abdulaziz qu'il racontera plus
tard je leur ai demandé aller avec mon
enfer il n'y aurait suivi aveuglement
voilà le ramadan est finie on lève le
camp et maintenant abdelaziz a décidé
d'attaquer ryad sans raffin avec ses
amis avec ses fidèles
il arrive de nuit près de la ville hélas
les chameaux avec quelques hommes pour
les garder il les place dans un endroit
où il sait pouvoir les retrouver et avec
les autres ils s'approchent des remparts
il ya là un cimetière au pied ne m'en
parle existe douleur sur la route de la
mecque
ils se cachent
on les a pas vus on ne les a pas
entendus ils ne sont que six qui
accompagne abdoul aziz sy tillaoui les
autres avec mohamed abdelaziz les a
laissés en renfort près d'une seat un ca
proche d'une maison la maison d'un
fermier qui lui résistent connaît bien
une frappe à la porte
on ouvre après avoir parlementé l'homme
qui ouvre à une lanterne
c'est bien l'ami thèmes durs à mal le
fair miami il fait entrer les hommes il
reconnaît abdel aziz c'est toi
abdulaziz l'autre le prononcer bras il
s'explique je viens reprendre ma
capitale
alors le gouverneur mais le gouverneur
il s'appelle à jinan sa maison est à
deux pas d'ici
tu pourrais l'avoir par la fenêtre s'il
ne faisait pas nui mais voilà c'est
qu'il passe la nuit un citadelle avec sa
garde dans sa maison il n'ya que sa
femme il l'a rejoint
chaque matin une heure après le lever du
soleil est aussitôt le plan d'abdoul
aziz est fait par les toits
il va gagner la maison d'hadji lane il
descend dans cette maison ils y trouvent
la femme d'à du lam et sa soeur il est
fait jeter dans une cave avec les
domestiques
elle a confirmé auparavant quand les
faits son mari arriverait le lendemain
matin après le lever du soleil
il envoie un homme cherchait son frère
il réserve
les voilà qu'ils rejoignent abdelaziz
ils sont 40 dans cette petite maison une
nuit entière à passer en bois du café
récite le coran et voici enfin le lever
du soleil
ces quarante hommes se tournent vers la
mecque et pris une heure plus tard la
porte de la citadelle s'ouvre que voici
à jinan qui paraît
[Musique]
comment
alors le bon café abdelaziz le bond à
léopard il saute dans l'escalier ouvre
la porte se jette sur la place se ruent
vers le gouverneur qui l'attend avec son
sabre les deux hommes c'est très doux
puis vers leur temps ils emploient
toutes les ruines
tous les petits possible qu'il va
s'engouffrer mais on le rejoint on le
rattrape et maintenant c'est un combat
intense et entre les hommes d'abdel aziz
et les hommes d'abus l'anaconda illégal
[Musique]
es tu là ne s'enfuient dans la citadelle
il veut se réfugier dans la mosquée et
c'est jean louis qui le rejoint
c'est fini vers leur est mort et peu à
peu tous les hommes d'un dylan meurent
aussi ceux qui survivent se rend et
bientôt abdelaziz envoie des crieurs
surtout les remparts et tout en haut de
la mosquée pour crier qu'abdel aziz est
de retour
il ment ça clame à sion dans la ville
tout entier vivent abdulaziz à midi les
maîtres de la ville
il envoie un message à son père revient
paix chez toi les marchands heureux lui
prêtent de l'argent
il va pouvoir relever les remparts
acheter des armes
parce qu'il attend le retour de rachid
et quand le père arrive c'est
l'apothéose
mais le père réunis dans le palais les
docteurs de la loi les notables lors des
six vieux fatigué je remets tout mais
pouvoir politique entre les mains de mon
fils abdel aziz et le garde simplement
le privilège d'être l'iman et de prier
dieu alors rachid cours bien sûr pas
tout de suite parce que il a éclaté de
rire à chine l'a dit le la pub est au
trou je le prendrais quand je voudrais
même ils laissent passer les et son bien
à tort parce que la ville devient
imprenable à force de se renforcer ses
défenses et quand il se présente il ne
peut pas rentrer norian et en plus il
apprend que abdelaziz est parti parce
qu'il parcourt la région il laissait de
rallier toutes les tribus pour
reconstituer son royaume et rachid
s'élancent derrière à la poursuite la
bio l'asie ce qui l'attend
qui l'attend dans une palmeraie avec des
sommes bien armés
voyez vous c'est une tactique n'est pas
du tout détruit
doit affronter face à face c'est un
stratège
les occurrences ils innovent comme
bonaparte avec d'innover il a nié ces
hommes vous allez vous cacher viserait
ses hommes darchy que vous n'êtes direct
quand il sort il pas les rater il ya
plusieurs attaques que ce soir et à
chaque fois nouvelle et qu'attendre la
nuit à répond combat et au matin quand
le soleil se lève de nouveau l'armée la
chine cet amphi ce qu'il reste du moins
trion total d'abdoul aziz il y aura
encore 26 mois d'affrontements avec
revers succès interventions des turcs
quelques fois qu'ils se mêlent toujours
qu'il n'en garde pas toujours d'un côté
on à londres un moment donné rachid va
même demander aux turcs d'envoyer une
armée à son secours
8 bataillon d'infanterie de batteries
d'artillerie il y aura bataille et salle
les hommes de abdelaziz ont très peur
des endroits si ce n'est les poulets
carterie ne connaissent pas
et parents le matin voilà c'est que
lecture peut qu'on fait on trop vite
leur succès pilleront le camp d'abdel
aziz et puis un peu plus tard les hommes
d'aziz qui a lui-même a été blessé dans
le combat qui héroïquement avec un genou
brisé raconté à cheval pour rallier ses
hommes tuent mais ils vont conduire
prendre les turcs en train de piller les
massacrer
et puis ensuite il est rare scelleront
tellement qu'ils saisiront leur réseau
et leur canon et alors que 2400 turc
était arrivé pour anéantir abiola disent
ils ne rentreront en turquie que 700
avril que ça vaut la peine qu'on succès
est finalement rachid et bien qu'ils
résistent poursuivra jusqu'à son corps
arrivera de nuit alors l'arachide se
battre a courageusement il faut bien
dire tu attendras criblé de balles c'en
est fini des dangers des régimes
plus et maintenant qu'il a écrasé les
turcs rh et est bien quand il revient
dans sa capitale
c'est son père abderrahmane qui convoque
est notable et docteur de la loi tout le
peuple de ryad et qui s'écrit je veux
que mon fils abdel aziz devienne roi une
immense acclamations monte vers le ciel
hélas ce qu'apportait abdourahmane c'est
l'épée de séoul le grand et paix qui a
déjà traversé les siècles dans la même
famille et c'est sur cet ep qu'il tend
d'abord vers le ciel pour saluer dieu
puis vers tous ceux qui l'entourent pour
recevoir leur serment c'est sur cet ep
qu'abdel aziz jure de conduire son
peuple vers de nouvelles conquêtes qui
seront non seulement la restauration de
l'unité arabe mais aussi la restauration
de la vraie foi celle des wahhabites sur
toute l'arabie clairoix et il
s'appellera désormais higgins et aude et
ben c'est rude mais ses vieux compagnons
continueront à l'appeler le léopard du
désert en souvenir du bon prodigieux
qu'il avait accompli ce matin sur la
place de ryad pour rejoindre le
gouverneur installé là par rachid
alors hemus m
et bien une série de c'est l'homme qui
réalise mois après mois année par année
un plan appelant remarquable
d'unification
alors les provinces après les provinces
tombe sous sa loi
elle n'est pas si facile qu'on le pense
parce que toute province absorbé risque
de se révolter elle se révolte souvent
il faut réprimer l'accord qui vont la
réprime sévèrement ce n'est pas un
sanguinaire qui me séoul mais il pense à
la vertu d'exemple il pense que s'il ya
mille rebelles et selon l'onu 300 et
bien les autres se tairont ce qui arrive
pour nous
[Musique]
ce royaume s'agrandit de cesse de
s'agrandir
[Musique]
la loi d'une série d' s'exerce sur les
territoires toujours plus vaste mais
regarde de me côté de la mer il sait
qu'un royaume qui n'a pas d'accès à la
mer n'est pas un royaume alors le golfe
bah oui le golfe mais voilà les turcs
occupe le golf encore les turcs
il faut dire que ils ont là des forces
assez faible et même ils ne sont pas
capables de faire régner l'ordre il y a
des habitants des villes qui s'en
plaignent amèrement parce que sans cesse
ils sont victimes
d'incursion de tribus viennent piller
chez de volley etc
alors quand abdulaziz leur envoie des
messagers pour leur dire si c'était moi
qui étais chez vous ici
ouah ça dans votre belle province dû à
ça et bien l'ordre règne aurait laissé
sa l'astuce suprême dit mme co2 parce
que bien entendu les habitants de ces
villes du à savon accueillir sa
proposition avec enthousiasme et quand
ims et aux attaques et bien à ce moment
là il va écraser les turcs littéralement
le gouverneur turc va devoir capituler
signé une capitulation
et d'ailleurs il aura les honneurs de la
guerre pourra se retirer avec armes et
bagages vers son pays d'origine
et voilà ims et houde qui entrent au à
ça qui est maintenant une province qui
lui appartient sera ça ou on trouvera
plus tard temps de pétrole
et s'avance vers la mer cette mer tant
convoité et quand il est là devant cette
même il est heureux profondément heureux
la guerre 14 18
eh bien elle rejoint même l'arabie et la
guerre ici ce sont bien des pièges pour
un prince oriental mais il faut dire que
ces pièges la ims et oud les contournent
tous
il commet pas d'erreurs l'erreur ce sont
les anglais qui la commettent quand ils
s'allient pour leur révolte arabe avec
laurent de sarah vit avec hussein
le chérif de la mecque en vérité il
aurait dû s'allier avec ims et août
c'est lui le seigneur du désert c'est
lui le roi du désert à leur insu ou
n'aime pas beaucoup et saine d'autant
plus qu'il ya entre une scène et lui des
des conflits de frontières
il y à toute une partie de la population
qui dépend de russell qui souhaitent
faire partie du royaume dit mme c ou des
mêmes qui revendique que cette
appartenance
ça ne fait pas plaisir à celui à qui
l'on le pose justement une telle
revendication hussein ne veut pas perdre
une partie de sa population
alors furieux par esprit de réciprocité
est il interdit aux sujets dit mme c ou
le pèlerinage à la mecque parce que la
mecque dépend totalement des scènes avec
et dans le territoire du sein or un
musulman se doit de faire son pèlerinage
à la mecque
est ce que vous imaginez l'état d'esprit
qui se créent parmi les sujets du sud à
qui l'on dit vous n'aurez plus à la
mecque puisque vous êtes sujet dean seo
il ya une colère violents qui se lèvent
contre du sein et on peut dire que le
peuple tout entier vient supplier et où
c'est d'obtenir que cet interdit soit
levée mc ou négocié deux mandats hussein
de permettre à ces sujets de retourner à
la mecque pucelle qui est renté des
opiniâtre du très mauvais caractère tu
sais ne répond pas du tout ils ne
viendront plus à la main alors que fût
il faut mais dire km séoul a lui aussi
très envie d'aller donner une leçon à
hussein dey de lui faire la guerre
son peuple entier voudraient faire
saigner il en a les moyens il le sait
bien et il ne fait pas cette guerre
pourquoi elle vient parce que les
anglais sont les alliés de ce n est que
si jamais il sait ou d'interviews contre
hissène
ce sont les anglais qui viendront à leur
tour donner une leçon à une serre où
elle s'en sera fini de son indépendance
il le sait parfaitement
il n'ya rien tant à quoi tiennent ims et
oud qu'à son indépendance il a toujours
été indépendant il le restera toujours
ce sera le seul souverain arabes qui ne
subira jamais aucun protectorat aucun
mandat le sel
[Musique]
alors il faut détourner la colère de son
île la détourne parce que précisément
les successeurs de rachi toujours les
mêmes ce sont au bas et on va les
écraser s'être peillon c'en est fini des
anciens domaines de rachi les
possessions de rachid feront désormais
partie intégrante du royaume dim ses
roues dans la guerre s'achève les arabes
en la pression d'une immense du prix
laurence d'arabie leur avait fait les
quantités de promesses
bien sûr on a créé un petit royaume
transjordanie pour abdallah fils des
scènes un autre royaume
on n'ira que pour faysal mais enfin où
est la promesse d'un grand royaume arabe
avec damas comme capitale
alors beaucoup d'amertume à profond
malaise que ims et où tu perçois
admirablement et qu'ils pensent utiliser
au mieux de ses propres intérêts et
hussein ne décolère pas et dit on devait
faire de moi le roi des arabes
on est obligé de l'envoyer lawrence
d'arabie pour le calmer ils veulent
jeter dans l'escalier heureusement il
n'y arrive pas ça n'est pas ça qui plus
populaire à londres
mc houde regarde observe à temps et
quand une scène dans un accès de
mégalomanie qui me ressemble bien se
proclame calife de l'islam vigueur du
prophète il y en a aucun droit colère
immense en arabie et à ce moment-là il
saisit à son armée ligue vannes
admirable armes et remarquablement
entraîné et mise sur pied par lui-même à
les trois groupes d'armées plein envoyer
la frontière de l'irak
l'autre à la frontière de la
transjordanie pour que les fils
d'hussein n'interviennent pas
le principal groupe make terreur à la
mecque hussein affolée qui réunissait
trésor dans douze automobile qui
s'enfuit qu'il embarque sur un bateau
anglais à djeddah on le reverra jamais
plus il abdique en faveur d'ali son fils
qui appelle les anglais au secours par
télégramme au secours au secours
les anglais répondre il s'agit d'une
querelle strictement religieuse la
grande-bretagne n'intervient pas dans
ces sortes de querelles ça c'est tout à
fait britannia
dans mon roman - ligue vannes entre dans
la mecque l'insee ou d'arrivée voilà
un cadeau
là
se dépouillent de tous ses insignes
royaux
ôte ses sandales semblant au plus
anonymes des pelles heures
s'avance pieds nus jusqu'à la pierre
noire
muhammad harun
aie aie
non
[Musique]
s'incline jusqu'à terre est là jusqu'à
la nuit tombée on va prier dieu qui lui
a permis de réaliser le rêve
qui semblait si insensé lorsqu'il était
enfant
ah la la
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
la conquête et dash et il avait 27 ans
quand il est parti pour conquérir
l'arabie
il ne laisse presque cinq ans pour tout
23 ans pour réaliser son rêve pour
atteindre son but
et maintenant il pense à son peuple si
malheureux si pauvre si démuni de tout
voilà au manque d'eau alors ils
convoquent des hydrographes américain se
cherchent et qui trouvent qu'il ya
beaucoup d'eau dans le sous-sol la ram
de l'arabie et on creuse des puits
la stade a connu qu creuse des canaux
est en effet partout des petites
colonies agricoles s'installe
[Musique]
il voudrait également développé
l'instruction publique oui mais il
manque cruellement d'argent va-t-il
échoué il n'a pas l'argent on voit là
que va se produire cligno oui j'avais
deviné du pétrole
curieusement ça ne fait pas beaucoup de
bruit on pourrait croire à une course
vers l'or noir non pas du tout c'est
qu'en 1920 le monde n'a pas besoin de
pétrole loin plutôt trop du pétrole
alors la découverte d'or pendant dix ans
en 1938 ce sont des américains qui cette
fois voudraient vérifier la découverte
de leurs compatriotes disant tôt et
fouillent partout leur rapport
la faire les faits d'une extraordinaire
bon ils vont conclure que non seulement
il y à du pétrole mais que le sous-sol
de l'arabie ressel certainement la plus
formidable nappe de pétrole du monde
alors là c'est toutes les compagnies
pétrolières rives samia les grandes
compagnies à la chaîne et sous standard
ses terres à la royal dutch mc août
très courtois très polis les
reçoit mais les renvois
le pas traiter avec les anglais les
hollandais n'ont plus les américains
plus tout mais pas avec une grande
campagne mais
avec une petite
il traite avec une toute petite comète
qui va s'associer avec une zone occupée
avec une troisième
[Musique]
et finalement ça donnera l'aramco qui
deviendra intégrant deux compagnies
américaines indépendant
c'est avec l'aramco que ims et aude va
littéralement transformé rabhi partout
des derricks par tout le pétrole qui
jaillit
partout des ports qui se creuse sur le
golfe des raffineries que l'on construit
et milliers de sujets divine ces routes
qui trouvent du travail avec de hauts
salaires la vie des gens l'action les
dollars qui arrivent les millions de
dollars qui a tombe dans l'escarcelle
dim ces routes qui peut enfin réaliser
son plan d'éducation qui peut enfin
couvrir l'arabie de route
chemin de fer d'aéroport moderniser son
pays
bien sûr ce sont ses fils théo jusqu'au
oui il donne l'élan mais c'était beau de
donner galant on estime maintenant
qu'avec les royaumes qui touche
il est l'un des quatre ou cinq hommes
les plus riches du mot et convient de la
seconde guerre on regarde encore plus du
côté d'ibm séoul il est très habile il
ne commet pas les erreurs de ses voisins
d'irak et d'iran qui ont trop flirté
avec hitler pas du tout il est là il
attend et quand l'angleterre lui demande
des avantages il atteint parce que lui
c'est plutôt d'un autre côté qui le
regarde du côté de l'amérique toujours
il dînait avec les anglais on n'est
jamais tranquille et cherche des
avantages politiques pas les américains
il a raison et après yalta quand
roosevelt lui envoie un télégramme cyr
je souhaite rencontrer votre majesté il
accepte on lui envoie un bateau de
guerre américain à djeddah les égards
extraordinaire on établit une tente de
mousseline blanche sur le pont pour
qu'il puisse faire ses dévotions du côté
de la mecque
il arrive sur le bateau de roosevelt
dans la mer rouge
i'm so glad to say you d roosevelt avec
son sourire a popularisé par le cinéma
la photo qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour faire plaisir à votre majesté et
ses roues d'immenses deux mètres de haut
une montagne devant le président
paralytique lui dit monsieur le
président c'est vous qui avez souhaité
elle voit apparemment c'est vous qui
avez des choses à me demander
voilà vous belt interloqué
lui qui n'est pas facilement un terreau
local et une conversation s'engage
c'est vrai qu'il a quelque chose à
demander roosevelt il dit sir vous savez
que on découvre des choses affreuses en
allemagne également fait périr des
millions de juifs alors les survivants
vous accepte très bien qu'on
les installe en palestine mc hugh
regarde rossfeld prononcer un seul mot
non normal sire vous devez convenir que
les colonies juives qui sont là depuis
des années ont réussi des choses
admirables
c'est vrai dit mme co2 mais c'est avec
l'argent que vous leur avez donné si
vous en aviez donné autant arabe il
aurait fait la même chose et voilà de
nouveau roosevelt interloqué dimanche
vous n'allez pas vous opposez en fait
que l'on s'occupe de ces malheureux
juifs certainement pas dit mme séoul
mais pourquoi chez nous c'est leur pays
pas du tout c'est le nôtre c'est déjà le
problème qui allaient empoisonner tout
l'après guerre qui nous empoisonne
toujours alors que préconisez vous
demande roosevelt à bout d'arguments
j'ai fait la guerre monsieur le
président moi même quand j'ai vaincu mes
ennemis j'ai toujours été à même
d'exiger d'eux ce qu'il faut exiger est
alors dire aux ailes vous avez battu les
allemands oui et bien fait un état juif
en allemagne alors la rougeole qui a
fait pas penser peut-être on verra
messire autrement eh bien monsieur le
président en effet il serait bon de
fixer un certain nombre de points
il faut que les états unis d'amérique
garantissent que les compagnies
américaines qui exploite mon pétrole
sandero
pour laisser ce pétrole là son
propriétaire c'est à dire leurs amis je
m'y engage des rousses belt
mais je souhaiterais avoir des facilités
pour les armées américaines en arabie je
vous les donne mais attention pour cinq
ans seulement cinq ans dans cinq ans
toutes les installations nous
reviendrons et par ailleurs j'ai désire
que les états unis 46 aucune attaque
d'aucune sorte ne sera portée contre
l'indépendance arabe que la garantie du
respect et les deux hommes se séparent
une serre où d'une fois de plus a gagné
sur toute la ligne
alors il ya les anglais qui s'agitent
dans dans l'ariège coulisses exclusive
mon dieu mon dieu qu'est ce qui nous
arrive on est en train de nous tourner
et churchill se précipite mais il arrive
trop tard et churchill dit je vais faire
un cadeau somptueux à votre majesté est
le cadeau arrive c'est une rolls alors
on a retiré le siège arrière et on a mis
un trône la place magnifique
or et veut le rouge oui mais voilà c'est
une voiture anglaise donc le volant est
à droite
l'éclipsé où le regard cela il dit alors
parce qu'il déteste être derrière en
voiture est alors je vais devoir
m'asseoir à gauche de mon chauffeur à
gauche moi il appelle le plus jeune de
ses fils lady prends ça fait onze ans
que tu veux et le président roosevelt un
peu plus tard lui envoie un dc3 quand je
vous dis que les anglais étaient plus de
force
alors oui il a joué il a gagné
et maintenant le monde de plus en plus a
les yeux fixés sur itunes et maintenant
il est l'homme
de l'après guerre
et maintenant il est à même de réaliser
tout ce qu'il souhaitait réaliser est
même plus
[Musique]
oh
pour
[Musique]
où
il s'est fait construire d'admirables
palais qui chantent la gloire de la
dynastie mais aussi la grandeur de la
rabine
dans ce ballet pourtant chaque soir ce
n'est pas les chambres luxueuses qui ont
installé des architectes qu'il va
rejoindre il fait étendre sur le dallage
une simple nat le vieux roi couche sur
cette note
et puis dès qu'il le peut il repart vers
le désert ce désert duquel il est né
ce désert où il a connu une seconde
naissance et la hune dresse sa tante et
dort là comme un peignoir
entré au palais il mange ce qu'il a
toujours mangé c'est à dire quelques
dates un peu de riz
un peu de liant
un peu d'eau on peut noter un peu de
café c'est tout
non
il était
altesse c'est la tradition du roi ibn
saoud se poursuit par conséquent que ne
s'est jamais interrompue
une phrase où justement avis neutre
alors que nous nous sommes dit au maire
que nous donnons au rabais
ouais cool que le match et que l'on met
directement en finale mais jacqueline
comme un long essai à douna loup chaque
drame là qu'elle m'a fait un deal bullet
et à la créatine encadrer notre bled
blâme le monde paraît acquise à
l'extérieur
bien que la vie du créateur comme maryse
savard a nommé c'est la cadre aziz waâda
leblad où il arriva chez robin
et c'est ici dans son palais de mort à
bâle plus simple de tout ce qu'il
continue à travailler
chaque année il se rend en pèlerinage à
la mecque il n'y manque jamais
et au printemps 1953
il se rendra de nouveau
au palais de tarifs chez son fils fait
salle où il s'arrêtait avant d'aller à
la mecque
mais cette année-là il n'ira pas plus
loin vitesse
depuis longtemps il est malade il se
déplace dans des chaises roulantes
mais là on ce printemps de 1953 il se
sent si faible qu'il comprend que
maintenant s'en est fini il va mourir at
il pensé à ce moment là à ce qu'il avait
déclaré quelques temps plus tôt à ses
envoyés le nu qui était venu lui rendre
visite et qui lui avait demandé mme en
phase i re comment expliquez-vous que
vous ayez pu parcourir une carrière
aussi fabuleuse
il avait gardé longtemps un silence
profond et puis il leur avait répondu
parce que tout au long de ma vie je me
suis conformé aux commandements de mon
dieu et à la parole de son prophète
oui peut-être at-il repenser à cela le 9
novembre 1953 quand il est mort on a
ramené à ryadh la dépouille mortelle du
roi ims et aude ses fils connaissez
depuis longtemps la volonté de leur père
il avait répété souvent je veux être
enterrée comme le plus humble des
croyants dans l'anonymat le plus absolu
avant de l'ensevelir on a compté sur son
corps 43 blessures par poignard par
sabre paraît p 43
et puis on l'a conduit dans ce cimetière
ce même cimetière ou 50 ans plus tôt ils
l'avaient attendu avec ses fidèles le
moment de reprendre ryad sa ville sa
capitale est là quand on se rend dans ce
cimetière il est très difficile
de retrouver la trace même de la tombe
dim ces routes aucun monument à la
gloire dit mme co2 mais quand on se
trouve en arabie saoudite quand on
parcourt le pays quand on interroge ceux
qui habitent
on comprend que le véritable monument
i'm so good
c'est dans le coeur de son peuple il
faut le chercher
[Musique]